[Music]
well hello dear friends welcome to our
program i'd like to know
this is a question and answer program
where you can send your questions to us
we'll do the research
and if there is an answer we'll try to
find an answer to your question
if it's a mystery
well we'll leave it in god's hands
if you want to send us a question i want
to give you the email address where you
can send us the question it'll be on
this on the picture
tv at some tv dot org
once again tv at some tv dot org it
should be on your screen right now
and we'd be glad to receive your
questions
and uh do the best to answer these
questions i have with me daniel miranda
who is associate speaker here at secrets
unsealed
newly arrived relatively speaking
we're glad that you're here with us and
we appreciate the wisdom that god has
given you to help answer the questions
at the program
amen it is my privilege to participate
in this program one of my favorites both
in english and in spanish amen i feel
the same yes
would you have prayer for us before we
begin to answer the questions absolutely
let's pray
dear heavenly father once again we come
before your presence
we understand that
in us there is nothing good
there is no wisdom there is no
righteousness there is no justice
but
we can claim it from you lord you have
promised us that if we lack wisdom
we can ask for it from you and you will
give it to us abundantly so we need that
wisdom to be able to answer these
questions we pray all this in the name
of jesus amen amen
okay we have a bunch of questions maybe
i can just show you what we have oh yeah
this plus some
and we continually receive questions
dozens of them every week
and so be patient if you don't get an
answer right away on the next program
realize that there are other questions
and we answer them in the order in which
they come
so the question that we have here i want
to address this to uh daniel
what is your opinion on the three most
debated textual criticism verses for
example the johannine comma
the story of the adulteress woman
and the long and short ending of the
gospel of mark
who is right
and who is wrong about them are they
late inserts etc
can we use ellen white as a textual
critic
clarification
she had after 1885 available the king
james version
and the english revised version later
known as the asv
so can her choice of particular
translations show us whether the
received text is the correct one or the
version of westcott and hort
a little example about revelation 22 14
she quotes all times the king james
version do his commandments and once in
maranatha blessed are they that wash
their robes
in interpreting scripture
the biblical research institute studies
volume 2 ronco stefanovic says that
evidence strongly suggests that wash the
robe robes is the authentic one who is
right ellen white or stefanovic
uh it's a
several questions and one uh what can we
say about those three passages that are
mentioned at the beginning of this
question yeah the first part of the
question deals with uh textile criticism
there is a
some controversy in regards to
this particular texts for example the
johannine comma
which is actually first john 5 7
and i think the new king james includes
it let's read it first john
or let's see
yes for there are three that bear
witness in heaven the father the word
and the holy spirit and these three are
one and there are three that bear
witness on earth
the spirit the water and the blood
and these three are
as one
so the the discussion here is that that
part from
verse seven where it says
the father the word and the holy spirit
and these three are one and the first
half of verse eight and there are three
that bear witness on earth
some suggest that that was not in the
original i mean actually you should read
it for their tree that bear witness
in heaven the spirit the water and the
blood and these three agree as one
mother translations that's the way they
have them
now
we don't need this text to prove the
godhead right there is abundant evidence
in other parts of the scriptures amen
about the godhead but
from my research
i don't have a
complete knowledge on this i haven't
gone in depth with this topic about
textual criticism
but from the textus receptors we know
that these portions are included but in
the
vaticanus cynaricos sinaiticus it is not
so
it is hard to determine
sometimes
but
some of these for example john 8 the
story of the adulterer woman ellen white
was it and she even has it in the desire
of ages right so
there is some truth in it
and she also quotes extensively versus
from the long ending of mark right
because there's a shorter ending i think
it ends at verse nine
in the modern version inspect
the shorter ending yeah yeah there there
are two um
two different types of manuscripts that
were used
for translation
one is the the text that was uh
established by erasmus
the textus receptus
the other is
vaticana sinaiticus etc
and
in the old testament there's no real
issue there's not huge issues about
translations because you don't have the
same uh same manuscript problem that you
have in the new testament
now uh the king james and the new king
james to a certain extent uh use the
textus receptus the more modern versions
use uh the the western text type
and so
the decision needs to be made as to
whether you're going to accept one group
of manuscripts or the other group of
manuscripts
the fact that ellen white makes a point
of the story of the adulterous woman she
doesn't only mention it in passing but
she actually has a lot to say about it
and the fact that she uses the last
portion of mark the longer portion of
mark in many places in her writings
would seem to indicate that those belong
in scripture
i haven't checked to see whether the the
johannine passage
is commented on by ellen white but as
you mentioned it doesn't really make any
difference whether whether that was
there or wasn't there because we have
other verses like matthew 28 right where
it says name of the father the son the
holy spirit uh also ii corinthians 13
verse 14 the last verse of second
corinthians you know we have three
present at the baptism of jesus so uh
you know and ill white recognize that
there might be messed translations and
there might be manuscript issues
in selected messages volume one she says
but that shouldn't shake your faith
because other verses of the bible will
clarify what perhaps isn't clear in that
one particular passage or verse yeah i
think and that would be the best
approach we should we can take
when it comes to
these uh apparent
contradictions or these apparent errors
that we might find in some of the
translations
i mean god's hand has not only been in
the inspiration of the bible but also in
protecting and preserving the truths of
the bible so there might be some things
that are not as significant and yet that
they don't alter
the message of the word of god right the
the main thing the main thing is the
focus of the message of scripture the
central message of the scripture
and if anything deviates from that well
for example if
if the modern versions had a verse that
says you know that we should consult the
spirit world
you would immediately know that that
does not belong to the biblical text
because of everything that the bible
says
but most of these variations are really
small variations they're insignificant
variations in the translation with with
some exceptions of course yeah
okay
mention is made particularly of
revelation 22 verse 14.
maybe we should kind of delve into that
a little bit revelation 22 verse 14.
you know sometimes
a copyist
undoubtedly was careless
in the way in which he
was transcribing
the words of scripture
wash their robes
is
stolas
whereas keep the commandments is tas
entolas which is very similar and so
it'd be very easy if you're being hasty
and copying that you might have
you know
copied the wrong word
however in this case
i think it's just arguing over nothing
because the book of revelation uses
wash their robes
and users keep the commandments
elsewhere in the book right
so so
you know whether it's
wash your robes or keep the commandments
in this specific verse i think keep the
commandments is the best translation by
the way
but there's other verses that speak
about keeping the commandments right uh
for example revelation 12 17 they keep
the commandments of god and then in
revelation chapter 7 they have washed
their robes and made them white in the
blood of the lamb so both are true
but you don't have to depend on
revelation 22 verse 14 to say that
you're going to have a group that do the
commandments because the other verses
make it absolutely clear amen
very good also
a little note here in regards to ellen
wise inspiration
you know he asked at the end who is
right ellen white or stefan knobik
we need to understand that
in ellen weiss time those are the
versions that she had available yes and
inspiration
picks the best resources at hand in the
time of the profit to make a point
right i mean today we have even more
resources and if you were alive she
would use more of the versions that we
had today we have today to make certain
points
but um
the bible itself is clear and ellen well
and why of course she supports
and seconds what the bible says
but
but sometimes
we cannot we have to be careful in
regards to her use of other sources and
versions when we try to build a case
right on the way she uses other
sources
you know
ellen white used the authorized version
um
occasionally
very occasionally
um you know the the more modern version
as it says here the um
how what is the expression the asv the
sv
yeah
english
the the english revised version
um
she used that version very sparingly
once in a while
and sometimes you know she translated
with
one way and the other way to give you an
example john 5 39 it says
you search the scriptures for in them if
you think you have eternal life and then
the king james says search the
scriptures
so one is in the imperative and the
other is indicative now the greek won't
tell you which is the correct
translation because it's identical the
imperative and the nominative are
identical in greek
so you have to take into the into
account the context
ellen height sometimes quotes you search
the scriptures for you think you have
eternal life
and another place she quotes uh search
the scriptures as an imperative both are
true
so so you know one or the other is not
going to change the tenor or the meaning
of scripture or even of that particular
verse right
very good
okay so
um i hope that that has been helpful uh
you know we are not expert textual
critics
i have studied quite a bit about textual
criticism but that's not my particular
field
but um what's the next question that we
have yes the next question comes from
robert
enac jeff
and
the question is actually he has two
questions
the first one is do you believe that god
in this day still allows hardships to
fall on his followers in order to awaken
them back into the gospel that's the
first question
that's an easy question um actually this
quarter we have a lesson or quarterly
in the crucible with christ yup and
there clearly we see that
uh god may allow sometimes trials and
tribulations to come upon us
to bring us back again into the faith so
this is one of the means that god uses
to awaken us and this happens in several
ways and in different circumstances god
has a lesson to teach us he has he wants
us to learn a song as we started last
week yeah as the bird in the cage he
wants us to learn a song
in
the darkness of tribulation advice isn't
the mystery of healing that's right so i
think that that question is actually
quite simple to answer god still allows
his people to go through trials
because trials are meant to make us
not to break us
in other words the trial is to make us
stronger in our relationship with the
lord more dependent upon him actually
and actually even the hundred and forty
four thousand ellen white says in the
great controversy that during the time
of trouble
uh the
the this time of trouble will
eradicate all the worldliness
and the drugs in their characters she
uses actually the word worldliness so
even they will be still even purified
after even being sealed through trials
even in their
sealed condition yeah actually the word
she uses is that he will consume their
earthlings personally
thank you because world is what doesn't
mean that they're still worldly focused
but earthliness means
god during the time of trouble wants to
consume everything that links them with
this world
like enoch right you know enoch reached
the point where god said there's no you
staying there
you know your your heart is up here your
mind is up here so come on up here we'll
walk down the street of gold
so so that's the condition that god
wants them to reach but even in eternity
once we receive our immortal and
incorruptable bodies we're still going
to grow amen we're never going to stop
growing
in our relationship with the lord it
becomes stronger and stronger the longer
we live even in eternity future amen
okay the second question from the same
brother has the gray shaking
begun
well
ellen white emphasizes that there are
three main things
that are going to shake people out of
the message
number one is worldliness
the attractions of the world
you know the
more concerned about what you have you
know your degrees and your money and
your houses and your cars
worldly things that's going to take many
people out
the second thing is false teachings
is going to also lead people leave the
church
but the final uh thing that is going to
lead to the great shaking is persecution
and
you know in a previous session we talked
about matthew chapter 24.
and so maybe we can go back there to
matthew chapter 24. and while we go to
matthew 24
there is actually one more reason
that was going to cause the shaking and
she says the the testimony of the
faithful witness to the leo this year
and that's that's related to
uh the one that we're looking at now
okay that's very closely related to that
people who are
lukewarm
will be shaken out when persecution
comes right
so matthew chapter 24
and verse 6 says you shall hear of wars
and rumors of wars see that you are not
troubled for all these things must come
to pass but the end is not yet for
nation will rise against nation and
kingdom against kingdom there will be
famines pestilences and earthquakes in
various places mark adds that there's
going to be tumults which is riots
wars are external wars riots are
internal turmoil in society
and then it says all these are the
beginning of sorrows and then notice as
a result of these disasters it says
then
they will deliver you up to tribulation
and kill you and you will be hated by
all nations for my name's sake
and then the very next verse is is key
because it says and then
in other words in the persecution comes
then
many will be offended
we'll betray one another and we'll hate
one another
that's talking about the shaking that
word offended is the same word that is
used in the parable of the sower for
those who were sowed in stony ground
and the seed fell it started to sprout
but when the sun came out it burned the
small plant and when jesus made the
application he said that they have no
depth of spiritual experience
they start their growth because they're
excited you know they suddenly knew the
truth they're excited about it they're
pumped up
but there's not that internal profound
work of the holy spirit upon the heart
and therefore when jesus interprets the
sun burning the plant as tribulations
and difficulties when they come they
fall away which is basically the shaking
so the great shaking is going to take
place when
the lukewarm will be shaken out they
will be vomited out of god's mouth
right
okay
i guess there were only two questions on
this one there are only two questions
so let's go to our next question what's
the next question
the next question comes from
jay richer
richter
dear sir i enjoy your program very much
if you already have a program on this
subject please let me know and provide a
a link i guess
how is this done
and the question and the title has to do
with the true use of the of the wheel
how is this done do i grip my teeth and
get rent
do i ask the holy spirit jesus or the
father to give me willpower
when i looked on youtube
those seem to be spiritualist
please help there needs to be a youtube
on this
okay so the question has to do with the
with the proper
use of the will
and ellen white states that the will is
the key to everything it's the key to
failure or it's the key key to success
in the christian life
so
is the use of the will something that we
do
you know i'm going to have the willpower
you know i'm a strong coffee drinker and
i'm going to use my power to quit there
are people who do that by the way there
are people who are not religious
that quit cold turkey so to speak
but is that what the proper use of the
will is for a christian
that's the big question
well ellen why says in the in the book
of steps to christ that an unconverted
heart
can make external changes
uh what some of the motivations will be
or can be
the love of reputation
uh selfish interest to uh attract the
attention to himself
but the
true
conversion comes from the heart
from any renewed heart that has been
given to the will of god
right yeah and and the aid of the holy
spirit and with the aid of the holy
spirit you know jesus said without me
you can do nothing right
so in other words
there are individuals who can overcome
bad habits by an exercise of the power
of the will
but in order to have a true
victory
over a sinful practice
you need to have
the help of the holy spirit you need to
invite the holy spirit into your life to
strengthen your will and to give you the
determination to make the change not
because you have to but because you want
jesus to dwell in your heart yeah now i
have a
i want to read a text this is found in
philippians chapter two
and we're going to read verse
13. and this text
talks about cooperation between us and
god it says for it is god who works in
youth both to will
and to do
for his good pleasure and notice he he
doesn't do it for us i mean he doesn't
make the decision for us but he works in
us so will in other words he puts the
desire he invites
and then when we
accept that then he also
does for us
for his good pleasure i have a quote
from actually i have several clubs from
ellen white
i would recommend my dear brother to
read chapter 76
mind character and personality volume
two there is a whole chapter on the
decision
and the will how to use the willpower
it says here in page
the will is the governing power in the
nature of man
bringing all the other faculties under
its way
the will is not the taste or the
inclination
but it is the deciding power
which works in the children of men and
to obedience to god or unto disobedience
so it is the power of god that god has
given to man now
this power has been
weakened or perverted by sin because we
gave our will to satan right but we can
still
choose
ellen white says that we are not
doomed
to keep sinning
because now satan has our willpower but
we can still choose to serve god right
we see examples in the bible in the
gospels for example the demon possessed
that even their weakest
efforts to reach out to christ he saw
that and he answered to their weakest
efforts for example that the the person
that was trying to talk to jesus but
then the demon spoke instead of him but
jesus recognizing the depth of his heart
that this man wanted deliverance right
and jesus
supplemented his weakness his willpower
and he enters and helps him
be delivered from the demons
there is another quote here that we find
in
in the same chapter
it says
um
[Music]
all right
here
everything depends on its right action
the tempted one needs to understand the
true force of the will
this is the governing power and the
nature of man the power of decision of
choice everything depends on the right
action of the will
desires for goodness and purity are
right as far as they go but if we stop
here
they avail nothing many will go down to
ruin while hoping and desiring to
overcome their evil propensities they do
not yield
uh
to they didn't they do not yield their
will to god they do not choose to serve
him yep so we are the ones that make the
decision yeah and you know the passage
that you quoted in philippians 2
has that combination
therefore my beloved as you have always
obeyed
not as in my presence only but now much
more in my absence
work out your own salvation with fear
and trembling sounds almost like we have
to work our salvation right but then the
next verse gives the balance for it is
god
who works in you amen both to will
and to do
for his good pleasure amen so god gives
us uh the power of the will
to exercise the power of the will
and
to do
his good pleasure and of course another
verse which is known by everyone
i can do all things
through christ who strengthens me amen
so it's not just gritting your trait and
saying i'm going to overcome this
whether it kills me no it's a case of
saying jesus take my will show me what
your will is and then give me the
strength through the power of your
spirit to overcome
that's the secret but but god won't do
for us what we can do for ourselves he's
given us the will so he's not going to
will for us exactly he's given us the
will and he's willing to guide the will
through the holy spirit yeah and then
maybe there is not much time to talk
about this but the armenian wesleyan
concept of the will the prevention grace
which is built on the case of original
sin they teach that
since we are born sinners the will is so
perverted
that we cannot we can never choose for
ourselves and that we need grace that
the so-called prevention grace but even
though the will has been weakened still
we can choose the god has given us that
right willpower and it is for us to
exercise that will power he's given us a
power choice never removes the power of
choice exactly
well folks unfortunately time flies when
we're having a good time
i hope that the answers to these
questions have been satisfactory um you
know the bible has the answers to the
questions many times that we have it
doesn't answer many mysteries we have to
just say thank you lord we'll ke will
allow you to keep this in your own mind
i hope that you'll join us next time may
god bless you and keep you in his care
amen
[Music]
you